hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's once again time to look through the
ps+ offerings in April 28 teams line up
all of the following games will be
available to download from Tuesday the
3rd of April with three out of the six
available on your ps4 let's start with
the headline titles on ps4 and first up
is Mad Max an action-adventure title
based on the movie franchise of the same
name you take control of Max in an
open-world post-apocalyptic wasteland as
you seek revenge on a gang of Raiders
that stripped Max of all his possessions
the emphasis of the game is mainly
driving and vehicular warfare but there
are portions of the game on put and
involve hand-to-hand combat your iconic
vehicle the magnum opus can be upgraded
in a range of ways making scavenging the
desert and hijacking enemy vehicles of
pleasure expect to play 30 plus hours in
Mad Max as the progression system draws
you in further upgrading armor and base
stats through challenges and exploration
even max can be customized to look
generally like you want him to you are
rewarded every step of the way and
although the tasks do become a little
repetitive there's more than enough
variation for me to recommend you
download and play this one take down
warlords destroy oil refineries cause
havoc for your enemies and be the rebel
you were born to be
IGN absolutely loved this game giving it
eight point four out of ten wearing the
most other outlet scoring Mad Max
between six and seven point five out of
ten are you gonna try it I'd love to
know your thoughts the driving theme
continues in our next ps4 title
TrackMania turbo don't expect simulation
here this is an arcade racer at its core
with over 200 tracks to race on over 4
locations including a rollercoaster
lagoon a stadium and the Grand Canyon
the pace is extremely high but has
enough forgive for new players to pick
up and play instantly track manias depth
comes over time as the ability to drive
on the edge of perfection and therefore
facing epic failure draws competitive
races in and if you do fail then the
race can be restarted instantly without
the need to finish the race or back outs
in addition to the campaign is a
cooperative mode which allow
to drivers to steer the same vehicle and
a great split-screen multiplayer mode
which brings back the good old days of
couch multiplayer but don't worry online
multiplayer is here too and it says
robust as you can imagine the majority
reviews for this one came in at around
seven and a half to eight out of ten
over on the ps3 the quality has dropped
quite a bit I do warn you and it's yet
another vehicular warfare game this time
set in space and has a name which sums
it up quite well this is in space we
brawl this is a local multiplayer title
for up to four players 11 weapon types
to try out and over 100 ship
combinations I tried it and I didn't
find it fun in the slightest but hey
this may be your type of game so Who am
I just like it off if you do try this
one please let me know in the comments
and anyway it's free ish so give it a
try another racing game is the next game
on the list for April tow you home you
control a toy car as you race around a
makeshift course on the floor of a
child's room to add a little more detail
collect coins find medals and pass
through every single checkpoint you see
it feels like it's trying to mix micro
machines and the burnout series but
doesn't do either very well let's see if
the Vita can offer something different
game number 5 for the month is 99 meters
which is a brawler inspired by 80s and
90s classics like final fight ins
Streets of Rage it may not look hugely
appealing but it's rather addictive and
perfect for your commute to school our
work with 6 playable characters and a
unique attribute system like speed and
strength 99 metres doesn't break the
side-scrolling beat'em of mold but it
does modernize a retro genre by the way
I don't speak Portuguese but I do
believe that 99 vidas translates to 99
lives and finally a retro masterpiece
which belongs in the past
Cubert I'm sure you know about Qbert but
if you don't he's the guy spouting
gibberish in wreck-it Ralph
I really can't polish this turd but if
you have a hankering for retro
brilliance try Q Bert rebooted on your
ps4 ps3 or the Vita okay so this month
isn't fantastic but hopefully you'll
download and play something for me I'm
going to jump back into Mad Max and
finish building my car to include
flamethrowers and ridiculous spikes I'm
also quite excited to play 99 metres but
my opinion means nothing what do you
think and what will you be down
loading I'd love to know anyway thanks
for your time I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]